thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
my favorite part is the lunch tray
aspect yeah it's the jalapeno cheddar
sausage I believe it is this is the
regular sausage and then this is
jalapeno last time we talked about
Cooper's Barbecue having trouble finding
good barbecue places out here so I was
like you know what my friends are
Coopers they were like we gotta you just
dropped him you're my favorite guests
okay
we got like brisket we got ribeye we got
sausage you guys talk for a little bit
and I'll be oh
I wish I had enough for everybody sorry
this is from Coopers and this is next
door to Billy Bob's is that where we
were talking about last time right uh
according to Billy Bob's I never had
this well the first time for everything
now you go back oh my gosh it's so good
guys
[Applause]
St Louis has great barbecue my brother
my brother is a barbecue artist he's got
this huge egg that can smoke for like 12
to 24 hours oh my mouth and then just
rib tips falling off the bone but this
this is tasty too so you know respect to
Texas it's all good okay it's all good I
love the competition is good and
remember that drives Innovation right
absolutely okay drives you'll keep it
water okay well speaking of barbecue so
what what were your summer vacations
like as a kid did you what what did you
do okay so the reason I found Coopers
was because I used to go to summer camp
as a kid I went to a camp called Camp
champ Champions it was a three-week
Sleepaway Camp in Marble Falls Texas oh
my gosh like right on Lake LBJ okay yeah
yeah apparently Drew Brees went there
too if anybody oh my God yeah weird but
to Camp okay so it was a sports camp and
that's where I discovered pickleball if
you ever played that I have I've heard
of pickleball I've never played it
pickleball is fun I'm gonna be a tennis
guy but I was early on the pickleball
train yeah okay it's ping pong standing
on the table
it's like a wiffle ball type of thing
with a paddle so okay yeah did you do
Camp as a kid I did I didn't go away for
three weeks though black people didn't
do that kind of thing
you go to camera you come home at the
end of the day
so you wait you play a nerd on the show
but not in magazines look at this this
this is the hottest picture ever what is
this for oh yeah
thank you yeah so I need you to play
this character I would love to play that
character
um what happened was we were like you
know what I want people to see me in a
bit of a Different Light well done thank
you yes yes I like to exercise cool with
art as well to see people like not in
like Typecast
I remember I was watching this as us I
think it was the first season and your
character Randall had like a shirtless
scene yeah and all of a sudden I was
like oh my God this man's ripped too
like yeah let's go like for the Nerds
nodes
I'm a ripped nerd as well yes totally
here's my shirtless moment I'm just
kidding
I'm just kidding
um no so let's talk about never have I
ever so this is the last season it is
the last season so kind of Bittersweet
has been so much fun but like it's
ending so do you think fans will be
happy with How It Ends or do you think
they'll I think and for fans out there
they're watching right now and that are
in the audience I genuinely don't think
that there could have been a better
ending as a whole for every character no
matter who you love no matter what story
lines you identify with or find yourself
writers oh my God the writers they went
crazy this season okay like they just
they really gave you like the perfect
send-off you know there are certain
shows where it ends and you're like man
like that just wasn't what I wanted for
the ending yeah granted like my
character Ben gross there's a bit of a
love triangle for those that watch and
those that don't like get on it
this man is awesome there will be
awesome too thank you you're welcome but
there will be a winner for that love
triangle I can't say who you will find
out so one of that outside of the fandom
is probably gonna be disappointed
they're going to be and the other side's
gonna be really excited
tune in June 8th all right you kind of
set it up though now if people are upset
they're gonna be like I blame him that's
fine
[Music]
[Applause]